Elite mammalian divers such as the sperm
whale can hold their breath for well
over an hour while they hunt in the
depths of the oceans while land mammals
such as humans barely lasts a couple of
minutes underwater without gasping for
air
an international team led by dr. Michael
Baron rink at the University of
Liverpool has now traced the evolution
of the oxygen binding protein myoglobin
to shed new light on how diving mammals
survive for such long periods underwater
without breathing myoglobin a protein
that gives meat its red color is present
in especially high concentrations in
elite mammalian divers so high that the
muscle is almost black in color but
until now very little is known about how
this molecule is adapted in champion
divers the team identified the
electrical charge on the surface of the
protein which increases in mammals that
can dive under water for longer periods
of time
by mapping this molecular signature onto
the family tree of mothers the
scientists were able to reconstruct the
muscle oxygen stores in extinct
ancestors of today's diving mammals all
proteins tend to aggregate at high
enough concentrations which may
seriously impair their function we think
that the high net charge on the surface
of myoglobin of all mammalian divers
causes electro repulsion like between
similar poles of true magnets and this
will critically allow a much higher
concentration of the oxygen storing
protein in the muscles of these divers
we're really excited about this because
it allows us to align their non-atomic
code changes that occur during the land
to water transition of mammals with the
actual physiological diving capacities
of the sandals the study also has wider
implications for human health research
this work improves our understanding of
how organisms evolved to avoid the
problem of protein aggregation which is
important for a number of human diseases
the research not only reveals mechanisms
behind one of the most extreme
physiological adaptations in the animal
world but also sheds new light on the
surprising evolution of one of the
best-known proteins
you